[Music]
senior sports Person of the Year
sponsored by peplos Briony frost Briony
only turned professional in 2017 but has
had a stunning rise to the top in the
male-dominated sports of horse-racing
she has had an amazing 2018 winning at
the Cheltenham Festival and becoming the
first lady home in the grand national
finishing 4th she's a dedicated sports
woman who is a role model to all who
meter
she's been chosen as an ambassador for
the jockey club and according to them
could be the greatest female jockey of
all time
Briony attended South Dartmoor Community
College where she excelled in all sports
and was recognized on the sports honors
board on completing her education
Sam Simmons Sam played local rugby from
the age of four and it was always
obvious that he had natural ability
20:17 was Sam's breakout year as he was
called back to the Chiefs for his
first-team debut against wasps scoring
two tries in the same season he went on
to play in the Aviva Premiership final
defeating wasps once again 23:20 Sam
alongside his brother Joe were part of
the exited Chiefs team in the Aviva
Premiership final finishing runners-up
to Saracens after topping the table
heading into the playoffs November 2017
saw Sam received his first call-up for
England for the autumn internationals he
also made his six nations debut scoring
two tries against Italy and winning Man
of the Match
Tom Manley 2018 saw Tom further enhance
his reputation as the top junior men's
goalkeeper in the UK tom is a committed
and modest young man who not only makes
every session at his local club that
travels to Bristol weekly for training
when he doesn't have GB commitments tom
has been a key player for gb under-19
steam in 2017 18 including the EU
nations tournament where he was awarded
the trophy for goalkeeper of the
tournaments recently tom was selected
for the England men's team and played in
the friendly against Scotland the
highest praise for Tom has come from
Olympic captain stating that Tom is the
best goalkeeper of his age that he has
ever seen
[Music]
you